once you've had a villain who can kill
half the universe with a snap of his
fingers what chance does any other
villain have of being that scary or
threatening let's take a look at some
villains from Marvel Comics who can give
fan OHS a run for his money when it
comes to being frightening Galactus
isn't necessarily evil but he's
definitely terrifying he's an
unstoppable force of nature and while he
doesn't actually want to hurt any of the
trillions of people whose lives he's
ended over the years that's not because
he has any affection for them it's
because he just doesn't care about them
at all lack tiss first arrived in
Fantastic Four number 48 by Stan Lee and
Jack Kirby kicking off decades of his
status as the definitive cosmic threat
in Marvel Comics he's a survivor of the
universe before ours reborn in the Big
Bang as the devourer of worlds
a creature seemingly beyond morality who
is driven by his endless hunger to eat
entire planets while he's been defeated
every time he's come to earth in the
past including once when he was
confronted with the souls of every
living creature he devoured in his
billion-year life
his very existence is downright
Lovecraftian for all its colorful
superheroes the Marvel Universe also
features a galactic force to whom all of
humanity is completely insignificant and
who might show up to end life on earth
whenever he gets peckish when Annihilus
was first introduced in the pages of
Fantastic Four he was called the living
death that walks and in the years since
he's more than lived up to that title
Thanos might have killed half the
universe and Galactus might devour
planets but they at least see what
they're doing is necessary
Annihilus on the other hand doesn't just
pillage his way across the galaxy he
enjoys every second of it at heart
Annihilus is an insect can as the ruler
of the chaotic interdimensional negative
zone he's got an entire swarm of space
locusts at his command ready to consume
everything in their path
that's exactly what happened in Marvel's
annihilation crossover where he led an
insectoid Armada to destroy entire
planets he's incapable of pity or
remorse and would casually snuff out
billions of lives just to expand his
empire the marvel universe is full of
unsettling monstrosity and compared to
them an overgrown octopus with a
gigantic I might not seem
scary the thing is that's not really Shu
McGrath it's just the way it appears in
the physical world in reality
well it's reality anyway it's part of an
extra dimensional race of beings known
as the many angled ones who ruled earth
as gods during prehistory it was cast
down by Crom the uncaring warrior God
worshiped by Conan the Barbarian but
it's been trying to find its way back to
earth ever since as Marvel's attempt to
bring some HP Lovecraft style horror to
the comics page Chu McGrath was
terrifying from its very first
appearance when it forced dr. strange to
kill his own teacher in order to stop
the evil possessing him from within
there have been evil gods in the Marvel
Universe for as long as Loki's been
around but Shu McGrath was the first one
to be inhuman and incomprehensible which
makes it way scarier as a creature who
exists entirely on the astral plane in
the realm of thoughts the Shadow King
has no body of his own he can however
take over anyone else's body
and consume their personality when that
happens we're not just talking about the
kind of mind control that's common in
superhero stories the shadow king wants
to experience the physical world however
he can spending years in a body using it
to live out his every hedonistic desire
and ruining the body in the process one
of the most horrifying examples of his
parasitic use of his host comes in the
pages of New Mutants when he took over
karma and twisted her body into
something monstrous from an indulgence
in carnal pleasures more recently he's
been used as the primary villain on the
TV series Legion which depicts him as
the chameleon-like creature of
corruption that he's always been in the
comics kilgrave also known as the purple
man isn't a god or a cosmic entity or a
noncorporeal psychic beam he's just a
man with one of the most simple super
powers imaginable he can make anyone do
anything he wants his slightest
suggestion is an irresistible command if
he tells someone to stop breathing
they'll suffocate without drawing
another breath he can't even turn his
power on and off when he was first
created he was just another mind
controlling super villain but over the
years his ability to effortlessly
control everyone around him twisted his
mind into something truly horrifying
when he was brought back to calm
as part of Jessica Jones's backstory his
true terrifying potential was on display
with his ability to rob victims of their
own will and autonomy combined with the
very real-world horror of sexual assault
comics creators borrow ideas from other
pieces of pop-culture all the time and
the brood might be one of the best
examples created in the pages of uncanny
x-men in 1982 they're pretty much just
the Marvel Universe equivalent of the
creature from Ridley Scott's 1979 film
alien in the interest of doing something
slightly different from that film though
Chris Claremont and Dave Cockrum created
an even more viscerally frightening body
horror concept while the xenomorph from
alien implants an egg that bursts out of
a human body and kills the host the
brood reproduce in another way their
eggs don't burst out they take over
their victims bodies and transform them
into new brood the host is still trapped
in there while their new form uses their
memories and knowledge to more
effectively conquer the galaxy in other
words the brood are the answer to the
question what if Xenomorphs were also
zombies and also trapped you in a
mutated body that you couldn't control
fear comes in many shapes and these guys
are at least three of them